c'est une rue aux résidences simple dans
le quartier du golf à Saint-Louis dans
la rue Borie de Saint-Vincent vivait
autrefois beaucoup d'ouvriers de l'usine
sucrière ils sont aujourd'hui à la
retraite le souvenir de Boris
Saint-Vincent est-il aussi
grégoritz ça Vincent
oui
un député
de la Fournaise c'est le premier à
l'avoir étudié
Jean-Baptiste Geneviève Marcelin Borie
de Saint-Vincent n'aurait jamais dû
aborder à la Réunion
à 22 ans notre gascon embarque le 19
octobre 1800 sur le géographe et le
naturaliste avec une vingtaine de savon
et de dessinateurs pour explorer la
nouvelle Hollande
à bord une querelle éclate entre Nicolas
Bodin le commanditaire de l'expédition
et les scientifiques à l'escale de
Port-Louis quelques-uns restent dans
Boris de Saint-Vincent
il est envoyé à Bourbon par le
gouverneur général où il débarque le 12
août 1801 le 5 décembre de la même année
il quitte l'île mais lors de ce cours
séjour lymphatidable naturaliste explore
le brûlé la montagne la côte Est gravit
deux fois les pattes orientales du
volcan sillonnent la Plaine des Cafres
et gravit même le Piton des Neiges de
son voyage il rédigera les premiers
écrits naturalistes édités sur l'île
Bourbon
des notes qui feront considérablement
avancer la connaissance notamment sur le
piton de la Fournaise il collecte dans
le même temps une immense quantité de
plantes pour constituer un herbier 113
espèces de plantes sont ainsi décrites
pour la première fois il quitte
définitivement les mascarennes en mars
1802 mais à sa mort en 1846 il ne laisse
que des dettes et ses filles devront
brader ce travail pour les éponger une
partie de l'oeuvre de Boris de
Saint-Vincent a donc disparu avec lui